hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast and
[Music]
I'm just checking it on you just check
it in to see how your weeks going this
is Memphis never is nor is it ever meant
to be an official podcast all right I'm
just [ __ ] just just popping in real
quick little [ __ ] half-hour yell see
now your workouts go and see how you
drive homes doing
are you listening at work oh you son of
a [ __ ] god bless you god bless you if
you can get away with it I woke up today
bulu dude and I've had this [ __ ] song
in my head and I might want to
fast-forward I forget how the lyrics go
with something like so I'll give you a
kiss after the lovin bah dah doo doo ba
be bee bop back who sang that song
dah dah Jude that's one of those [ __ ]
guys who's probably you know we recorded
it as younger than I am but when I look
him up he's going to look like he's 106
let's see after the lovin lyrics you
guys no no oh oh
Engelbert Humperdinck Engelbert
Humperdinck where the [ __ ] is it the
Millennium collection the Millennial
collection can we have a series of songs
that are safe for everybody could that
be okay sorry I got my shitty recorder
I'm on the road here chicks are the
Millennials also I sing you to sleep
after the lovin with the song I just
wrote yesterday and I hope you can hear
what the world's and abuse it I got my
own the rest of the [ __ ] song goes
that's one of those songs all you know
is after
the lovin you just sit there mumbling
along everybody good after the lovin
right oh [ __ ] oh my god that just
reminded me of a [ __ ] joke I want to
do oh wait a second I got to write this
down Sweet Caroline [ __ ] you [ __ ] Red
Sox I got a small most stressful gigs
this is the last stressful gig I have
all year I got past all the [ __ ]
press you know what I mean so all the
press I had to do for that [ __ ] thing
you sit down you like how's this going
to go allows this one cause that one
going to go and you get all through it
right I had a bunch of [ __ ] you know
I did that gig for the cops the
motorcycle cops in California God
somehow got through that one I wasn't
sure how that was going to go that one
ended up going great I got one last
[ __ ] thing and once I get past this
gig I have nothing but comfort zone gigs
for the rest of my year today I'm on a
roast the retiring David Ortiz's number
and he wanted to have a roast for his
for his charity and what's hilarious is
I don't think he's going to understand
most of the [ __ ] like he one of the
comedians he was talking to so you know
I went out I left one of the people
laughing but you talked real fast I
don't understand what a lot of it is
[ __ ] which I understand cuz I went to
the Dominican Republican they started
roasting me I'd be like eh I just keep
waiting for them Rojo
that's the word I'll be waiting for aw
they're talking about me cabeza Rojo
whatever the [ __ ] they're going to say
okay basa how the [ __ ] you say I don't
know so I got some good ones I got some
good ones how do you roast a rotis you
know [ __ ] drunks there Pedroia is
going to be there and you know these are
all athletes that play for Boston teams
so all of them have won championships
that's just how it is around here
people this isn't like your towns we're
roasting one of your local athletes
three out of the four sports you know
maybe you want one championship it'd be
a [ __ ] joke see what other city would
be like New York you can [ __ ] destroy
people [ __ ] destroy people because I
don't think there's anybody left on the
Yankees and the gun knows football teams
turnover you can really [ __ ] I mean Eli
eight always just make fun how he looks
let me get trash the next trash the Mets
trash the Rangers those Brooklyn [ __ ]
teams that has to be like a two-part
[ __ ] roast Pittsburgh be a hard place
you know that'd be a hard place I maybe
you can Trash the Pirates but I mean
[ __ ] Penguins back-to-back and
they've won big one three with Crosby
Big Ben's one two and you know once
you're his [ __ ] would be taking off the
tears outwards they take it off the
table I don't talk about the egg hey hey
hey could you not so anyways I just have
to get through this so I figure I'm
going to sit there and get called a
cancer patient for [ __ ] an hour
they'll make fun of my black wife and
then I just all I got to do is just go
up there for ten minutes
and trash David Ortiz okay it's going to
be fun
I so want to tell you some of the jokes
but I know you can't go to tweet them
and then people read them before I get
there and I need every laugh I can get I
literally was [ __ ] writing this [ __ ]
like I can't sit down and write I can't
do it you know yeah but think of how I
read out loud okay now imagine me trying
to put those words down onto a piece of
paper okay how I do it is I put my
daughter in the stroller and I walk
around the block a big huge walk around
the block and I'm just talking to myself
and everybody thinks oh look at that
daddy so engaged with his child and I'm
really coming up with roast jokes and
then I sat down and I smoked a cigar by
myself
on my back porch and I just video myself
and I just say [ __ ] into my [ __ ] then
I'll have like 40 videos all like 9 10
seconds long and then I just transcribed
him on the plane most of them now I'm
trying to put them into an order where
they flow and I'm actually writing them
down but I'm too late for the tella
process so I'm gonna have to go up there
old school to [ __ ] pieces of paper up
there
I know people good people you just will
do you poopy good look over your
shoulder douche air it is the
teleprompter see that the rabbits
already in the Hat I never do these
roast things either I never do them I
thought all of those Comedy Central ones
after a while they just went off the
rails you know I mean it just everything
was like the [ __ ] I don't know
everything was the goddamn same same
[ __ ] stupid joke you know hey I'm not
saying this guy beat the dubu but when
he Wacka Wacka Wacka Vogel AIDS
9/11 you know whatever the [ __ ] you
could say that would you know be the
most you know air-quote edgy [ __ ]
thing even though it was totally [ __ ]
predictable so uh yeah I never got into
those things you know I wouldn't [ __ ]
your mother with dogs getting a trapeze
with your [ __ ] scurvy plus I don't
get roasted somebody you don't know like
the most jokes I have for the people on
this is for Lenny Clark because I know
Lenny and I love Lenny so I got stories
I know what he's done I got all this
stuff I can [ __ ] on him I have more [ __ ]
about Lenny Clarke than I do you know
Gronkowski's a tough one too because
everyone's going to go he's [ __ ]
stupid so I'm trying to think of another
angle so really isn't one
something about spiking a baby I have no
idea so I'm out I'm a little amped up
for this thing a little nervous will
amped up I can't [ __ ] wait all I know
is this is one of these deals which is
just like just [ __ ] bring me up bring
me up
I can do this thing and then I can relax
then I can relax it's all I need to do I
just got to get through tonight just get
through tonight tonight tonight whoa
then it's easy then there it's [ __ ]
easy I go back to my regularly scheduled
stand-up dates you know God willing
we'll get a third season of emphasis
with family I've already been through
that [ __ ] twice I'm right back into my
comfort zone
you know so I got here last night and
you know I cab it over to the [ __ ]
laughs Boston because everybody was
going over to run their roast [ __ ] and I
don't want to do that I I just wanted to
do stand-up just go up there and be
funny you know warm up loosen up a
little bit then tonight I'll just
[ __ ] do the jokes that is the game
plan they're not it printed out nice and
[ __ ] big the font is going to be nice
and big so there's no way for me to [ __ ]
these things up and I'm just going to go
right down the dais I figure it's like
[ __ ] weird again we got Adam ray we
had we had [ __ ] Suzy soliloquy we got
a Mikey monologue the dory above eight
or nine [ __ ] but I do a minute on
everybody I'm done but I got to do David
the [ __ ] longest so I got I got you
know he's actually surprisingly not that
hard to roast even though all the [ __ ]
that he did you know you can even get
that guy pretty good Pedroia is
difficult once you just get past you
know it's just a little fella you know
then it's like well now what do I do
now for chrissake who's texting me now
huh anyways yes and once I get through
that the rest of the year is downhill
you know down [ __ ] hill you know and
I've already worked it out thinking if I
get if we get a third season all right
I'll get up early in the morning right
spend some time with my daughter and
then I'll go over to the little [ __ ]
reversal place you know I'll do my
little drum drum
in there and then I go over I [ __ ]
write the [ __ ] then I'm home that's the
game plan then I get home take the
daughter walk around the block some
point me my wife passed each other in
the halls were like who are you again oh
that's right we're married and then
that'll be my year so I give you a kiss
after the lovin
Engelbert Humperdinck who [ __ ] knew
who knew um who knew that that was going
to be in my [ __ ] head today I had no
idea
so anyways one of my new hobbies when
I'm on the road is I watch Fox News and
I watch CNN and I just flip back and
forth between them it is [ __ ]
fascinating like I don't even know what
those channels have become I don't know
what they ever were but it is not news
they're basically just yelling at each
other now that's the [ __ ] it's like
it's like you're watching a sitcom you
know all right his is the idea is the
pitch for the show this is two news
channels one's conservative and this
one's liberal I was watching that Sean
Hannity guy and one of his stories was a
story about somebody on CNN
you know the chick with the the Mary Lou
Retton haircut whatever [ __ ] name is
the one who cried when Trump got [ __ ]
elected which really was a low point in
journalism
Hillary lost she didn't get assassinated
Jesus Christ even [ __ ]
what's-his-face held it together when he
said JFK got killed [ __ ] Donald Trump
gets elected you [ __ ] sit there
blubbering but God's sakes woman get a
hold of yourself so anyways I ain't
[ __ ] was saying he has her picture up
there and it says conspiracy theory
because of whatever the [ __ ] she said I
don't know I don't even know I'm just
sitting there going like this [ __ ]
guy is doing a new store
worried about a newsperson on another
channel this is news when I was growing
up like you know it Tom Brokaw was not
doing stories about Sam Donaldson you
know and only white men gave the news
not kidding I have no I don't know I
just don't know what the [ __ ] it is
anymore but I got to tell you it's
really entertaining you got to do it
people you got to step out of this
[ __ ] liberal conservative thing you
got to just step back and just enjoy it
for what it is it is just a bunch of
people who have just disappeared and I
don't there they all need like a [ __ ]
they all every one of them needs to take
like two years off you don't I mean I
think they should send them all at first
two separate places and then you
gradually get them react LeMay 'td as
human beings right and you just kind of
take centum to like a camp maybe they
start playing a softball game but you
know it's not Fox News for CNN you got
to mix up the players you know I mean
it'll ruin the rivalry like you know
when the NHL went to Russia to play the
Russians and all those [ __ ] you know
the Rangers were hanging out with the
Bruins and the Flyers were hanging out
it just people started getting drunk
together now you know you're all right
you know kind of ruins it but um
Fox News was going off you know that
otto warmbier story that [ __ ]
horrific [ __ ] story
[Music]
you know everybody like judging the guy
go oh you know what the [ __ ] he take a
[ __ ] poster for it's like any time
there's posters at my shows people
always take him it's the end of the show
gives a [ __ ] something you do you grab a
little souvenir or whatever me
technically it's stealing but who gives
a [ __ ] I mean is that that is that
enough warranted to give guys 15 years
hard labor he was there because of our
foreign policy you know that's why they
don't like to that where this and their
that and we're [ __ ] economic
sanctions
in all legit they don't like us like how
I just said that to you guys like that's
actual news so Fox News was doing this
thing where they were like they were
going back and looking at [ __ ] that like
some chick said on Huffington Post and
this Larry Wilmore what the [ __ ] he said
when he first did he did a bit about
like you know you know calm the frat boy
and like basically they didn't have any
sympathy for the guy you know but now it
plays out way weirder because the
[ __ ] the kid got killed over there so
this it Neng you know the whole [ __ ]
thing was just fascinating to watch and
like Fox News is just like these people
are terrible the book you know and just
taking it kind of like it's face value
not taking into how was written why it
was written
I think everybody's [ __ ] up in it to
be honest with you I think it's [ __ ]
up to do that white privilege thing I
understand it but the yeah I get that
whole thing well look what he deals with
we deal with in this country something
you can't understand I am which I get
that point but I don't know when you
take it to the point of having a little
bit of joy about it which I probably
would if I was on the other side because
I am NOT a mature human being and I have
anger issues I know that I would
probably come in at it like that too but
it takes a lot to have empathy that's
what I've learned you know to me because
as much as that chick on the Huffington
Post was making some good points it's
like well I don't see empathy on your
side though and I'm not talking about
towards white people it's like look at
you [ __ ] close as you're saying I'm
complicit in your suffering what about
the people that make you [ __ ] close
all that sweatshop [ __ ] labor do you
think about the five-year-old that sewed
you [ __ ] skirt together you don't
give a [ __ ] it's you too busy focused on
that's what human beings do we focus on
our [ __ ] that's what I learned watching
CNN oh man I watched all these [ __ ]
white guys
havin a [ __ ] say this about this other
white gay they're all up in [ __ ] arms
the same [ __ ] people the same kind of
white people than with somebody black
gets Juggalo just you know just do what
the police say you'll be fine
uh you know stop wearing hoodies you
know they just in any just [ __ ] get on
with their lives
now all of a sudden they're [ __ ] up in
arms about this [ __ ] dude you know but
that's what people do though so I just
kind of saw second you know what you do
is you insert yourself into the
situation and if you see a white person
and you're white you go oh my god that's
terrible that could have been me I think
you know maybe white people black people
also need to be sent away you know
separated first and we all just you know
kind of mix up and play softball to go
right but that doesn't work look at that
guarantee Eagles you went to that
country just [ __ ] concert and he
starts dropping the n-word you know I
don't think these robots coming is going
to be a bad thing you know be weird if
but maybe they'll be like improved human
beings you know be [ __ ] weird is if
they actually they made them so [ __ ]
life like that they'd be like [ __ ]
racist robot you know just walking in a
paintball don't want to work a jury of
your not tears has [ __ ] convicted you
know I actually just kind of I mean
because stories kind of like losing
momentum but if you just watch it and
you just listen to people do they just
see the world out their own [ __ ] head
and they just talk
I don't than they talking just [ __ ]
sit there and join it like
the people that [ __ ] white dudes on
fox news are the whitest they look like
you know when they make those
coming-of-age movies in the 80s and
there'd be those [ __ ] preppy frat boy
guys like you looking at I'm going like
you do seriously dress like that man I
guess this is sort of [ __ ] judging
them too but like oh there's one guy on
there it's just like dude you look like
the date rapist slash your girlfriend
died during air-quote rough sex she was
into it and it got carried away this is
what that guy looks like I don't know
the whole [ __ ] thing is just it's a
weird thing but what I have learned is
people the suffering they see is their
own suffering and it's very hard to look
at other people suffering and to try to
you know take time out of your day to
understand it regardless of what color
you are is kind of what I learned from
that and people who actually do are way
beyond me and then beyond that people
who then [ __ ] try to do something
about it
you know like someone who would actually
try to do something about sweatshop
labor going like alright well I'm only
going to buy clothes that are in this
country I tried to do that for a second
and I did that like [ __ ] 15 years ago
and the options were ridiculous I was
like I'm not wearing that out to a
comedy club I'm going to get destroyed
so I said to hell with these [ __ ]
kids who sew together my shirts I was
protecting myself when I was going down
to the cellar because I didn't want to
get trashed so I guess I'm saying I'm a
selfish piece of [ __ ] I think that's
what I learned watch enough Fox and CNN
I think I saw a lot of myself like these
guys are just [ __ ] into their own D
like chicken The Huffington Post
completely 100% into her own [ __ ]
deal
you know the whole [ __ ] world the
same way with those Fox News guys the
entire world is the way she sees it and
those guys the entire world is the way
that they see it and they just cannot
[ __ ] on
the other levels fathom any others any
other reality out there you know I think
a lot of times I listen to feminists I
just listen to what they say and I just
switch around a couple pronouns
from-from
men you know he to her and it's just
like you literally if I [ __ ] took
what you just said and I took out all
the the men eggs replaced it with women
in her and I swear to god you would
sound like a trump supporter all right
I'm off my [ __ ] soapbox all right I
was up there for a minute now I'm off it
what I'm really trying to say is you got
to [ __ ] watch Fox and CNN and pull
yourself out of it you know what I mean
it's like your team got knocked out of
the playoffs and you just sit there and
you just watch it
and just watching these [ __ ] people
it's not none of it is news anymore it's
it's just like I don't I don't know what
it is it's their [ __ ] opinions it's
like two op-eds it's like everybody's
Andy Rooney except there's no humor in
it anymore they just [ __ ] I guess I'm
doing that now my podcast look it's
affected me bill where's-where's to
silly jokes you know what maybe I'm out
of jokes and I have any [ __ ] jokes
left I so want to read you guys some of
these [ __ ] jokes I'm going to blame
David Ortiz for childhood obesity
[Music]
there's one for you
oh the Red Sox oh yeah I got some good
[ __ ] for them just to general I don't
have a lot of Pedroia stuff Gronkowski's
hard to because I'm going on last and I
know everybody's going to be ad not
saying this guy's dumb but he [ __ ]
oka welcome Annie Walker welcome as I
got [ __ ] I can't do that joke now what
do I do
I don't know I'll figure it out and
worst case scenario i bum and it's over
in ten minutes and then when i do i just
slowly walk out of the [ __ ] room you
know and i cant drink myself into the
stupor you know why cuz old billy no fun
Billy no fun that's right on and off
Billy is what I really am since I
decided to be Billy no fun I've drank
Saturday and Sunday both weekends and I
have not drank Monday through Friday so
[Music]
I'm not drinking tonight that'll be four
days in a row I won't drink tomorrow and
then I'll fly back saturday I'm not
gonna drink that day I think I'll be
good I'll put a good two weeks [ __ ] and
run together maybe not quite
there's the following weekend I'm
working with virzi who knows I don't
know but I got it I got a dialed down
though I got it back under control I
like to think you know cuz I said so I'm
going to Billy a-a-alright where I'm
going to give myself a chip every five
days I get a chip and then I get a drink
that's how my AAA works you know that's
the problem with addicts it's just so
all-or-nothing
it's why they're [ __ ] miserable so
like Lana just have like a glass of wine
and just [ __ ] relax alright you
gluttonous psychopath I'm not a fan of
addicts I'm really not most some of them
are cool but in general there's some of
the most selfish [ __ ] people you ever
going to meet on the face of the [ __ ]
earth and they got that built-in [ __ ]
excuse it's not me it's the addiction so
I love South Park they're like no no no
but you did that yeah it's not me it's
the disease
and [ __ ] out of here every time it's
diseased it's never you it's never you
all right I think I said enough stuff to
offend people here then I get some
[ __ ] emails all right let's let's
read a little bit of advertising if five
fold club looking good doesn't need to
cost a fortune because five fold club is
revolutionizing the way men shop at five
Foca they found a way to make great
looking clothes affordable for everyone
can they say the name of their [ __ ]
entity one more time why wasted at the
mall or wandering around in the stores
each month they send you a curated box
it's one of most overused [ __ ] words
ever curated box you know like these
[ __ ] geniuses staring at shirts and
getting a couple of stripes and a
[ __ ] polka dot guys want to get some
lunch two to three items that are
hand-picked to match the current season
and your style bifocal partners with
cutting-edge designs and brands so
you'll get the same quality as top
designers they've been helping men with
fashion for over 15 years 15 years I
don't [ __ ] heard of these guys will
have been doing it it's been a covert
operation and to shipped over 100,000
men every month Chris Paul and Mike
Wahlberg use five fold club and 5fo is
featured in GQ vice and InStyle
among other publications they know what
they're doing so if you don't that's
okay because five fold club how many
times can they say this has got to be a
record we'll help you build your
wardrobe how many [ __ ] times we said
the name okay there's a title one two
three two two two four five six
seven eight nine
this weed has nine [ __ ] five folk
clubs and now I just said that's that'll
be ten and as a member of five-o club
you'll also receive up to fifty percent
off items in their online shop and
access to exclusive Members Only Members
Only items like the jackets free
shipping and sizes size exchanges go to
500 club calm now and enter the promo
code burr and they'll give you 50% off
your first month package plus a free
pair of sunglasses that's 50% off your
first package at five foe Club spelled
fi ve 5 fo you are o club comm promo
code ber 500 club comm promo code burg
Jesus Christ oh my goodness here we go
lift everybody lift this CN n of
rideshares
that's why I look at it the other one
that rhymes with mover they like the Fox
News you know they don't give a [ __ ]
right if you're white get in the [ __ ]
car we don't give a [ __ ] what your
priors are lift is like wait a minute
have you done anything bad because you
did something bad it would really be bad
if you were driving people around you
know mover doesn't give a [ __ ] right
they don't give a [ __ ] all they need is
white skin a little bit of freckles and
you're [ __ ] hired that's a god that's
a truth I think they're actually Nazi
hunters are looking in to see who runs
that [ __ ] company I'm just saying all
right but lift lift these are the nice
people lift knows that they're drivers
or what keeps them moving so they do
everything they can to make sure their
drivers are happy on every trip this is
the ride-sharing company that believes
in cheating people it's people better
lift believes that being a ride-sharing
driver should be fun if you're having a
good time
so was it passengers so I mean I should
be wearing sandals when I read this
sitting [ __ ] in the lotus position
lift was up was the first to offer
in-app tipping when you drive for lip
you lift you keep a hundred percent of
the tips
drivers have been paid over 200 million
in tips since the feature was introduced
and a hundred and seventy million of
that was spent on yoga classes the rest
on tofu Express pay let's drivers get
paid almost instantly instead of waiting
weeks lyft has even taken the guesswork
out of pickups the new ant device uses
color-coded coding to help passengers
find their drivers you can earn hundreds
of dollars a week plus tips want to earn
more money drive more it's never been
easier to give yourself a race it's a
simple formula happy drivers means happy
passengers maybe that's why 9 out of 10
lift rides get a perfect five-star
rating go to lift calm / birt'day and
yanking and you get a $500 got new
driver bonus that's lift ly ft Lima
Yankee Foxtrot Foxtrot tango calm / /
lift calm / / limited time only terms
apply bow to do biondi's me on DS I
can't do that I was gone I was going to
say that I can't do that one I thought
about that kid in [ __ ] Korea I can't
do that one see this is the dangers of
this you got to have it worked out
alright let's start over again what's
something a lot more safer we on DS me
on DS laying here and dirty socks doo
doo doo doo me undies the undies velvet
up against my cook I love when I put
those two [ __ ] drawers on my name's
bill it is in one I don't know all right
elevate your underwear game to the next
time to the next level with me undies
you perfected your wardrobe but what
about this stuff not everybody gets to
see we're talking about your balls here
and you dick or you clamp whatever you
got down there maybe or hermaphrodite
maybe you have all three you know would
it be nice if there was something nice
and soft up against this of your
choosing
that's how am i taking the subway during
rush hour either alright if you've been
settling for store-bought underwear five
packs I have something that will change
your life for the better the undies I
don't understand why you're settling for
store-bought underwear like that's a
difficult thing to [ __ ]
to do I guess going to the mall can suck
right especially on Black Friday what's
the first thing you put on the last
thing you take off its your underwear
unless you met the McConaughey make your
most important piece of clothing the
best it could be with me undies what is
me undies all just seriously thought
feel-good undies delivered right to you
[ __ ] dua me undies are designed in LA
and made from sustainably sourced micro
motile modal a fabric three times softer
than coffee cotton coffin cotton me
undies softer than soft luxury underwear
it comes in an ever-changing selection
of classic colors bold shades and
adventurous patterns you get a tiger on
your dick so you can tailor your undies
to your own personal style and guess
what you can save time and money each
month with a monthly subscription and if
you're not ready for a scription hey
that's okay man you can still save
that's because the undies is offering
you 20% off their first pair just use
our special URL the undies comm slash
burn get 20% off your first pair so go
ahead revamp your underwear drawer you
deserve it once again that's my undies
com / / my undies calm / / you know I
had the best rant about politics I've
heard in a while he's [ __ ] Jimmy door
Jimmy door unlike me is actually
informed and he was calling somebody out
on just [ __ ] doing all these Trump
jokes and was just calling him like a
corporate liberal just acting as though
all of this [ __ ] didn't exist during the
Obama presidency all of this you know
people upside down in houses these
never-ending [ __ ] wars all of his
[ __ ] everybody gets all amped up about
ties he says it way better than me
I forget what what thing where he's on
on the internet but I'm considering
moving my operation over there because
YouTube is a [ __ ] ripoff they're a
bunch of goddamn thieves I told you the
deal over there if your video gets
flagged then you don't get the
advertising money yet they still play
the ads so it's like well who gets the
money then they tell no nobody
it really they get free ads so what
stopping the advertisers from flagging
every video they bought time on they're
full of [ __ ] so I'm thinking that
pulling my channel and putting it
somewhere else I don't know I don't know
the [ __ ] to do who knows
alright simply safe everybody you can
rest easy when you protect your home and
family with simply safe when you install
your simply safe home security system
you're arming your home with a powerful
powerful sensors that tell you if a door
opens or a window breaks
it's a burglars worst nightmare is it I
mean I think having like you know I was
always thinking what if you had like one
of the most poisonous snakes in the
world right in the world world world
right and then when you leave at night
right before you leave you [ __ ] you
let the thing loose in your house I'm of
course not really thinking this through
like eventually I have to come home but
because I never fantasized past the
person coming in you know and the guys
like trying to Jimmy the lock and as
it's doing it that [ __ ] Cobra comes
up you know doing its little [ __ ] you
know dance right the snake you know just
waiting for that guy and the guy comes
in he sneaks in and thing it just
[ __ ] bites them a little black mamba
in there or some [ __ ] then you come home
with like your [ __ ] beekeeper suit on
going is snakey snakey snakey snakey
snakey or you know you can do you just
get simply safe that would be the worst
nightmare you know what about a komodo
dragon they just bite your leg and then
just follows you around the house to
your [ __ ] start collapse starts
eating your guts something that W I
think that would be a worst nightmare
but evidently simply safe is right up
there with Komodo Griff you can't afford
a Komodo dragon or don't have a black
mamba guy simply safe is what you want
there's a 105 decibels siren that alerts
you at the first sign of trouble you'll
have a dedicated team of security
professionals watching over you you 24/7
ready to send the police what do you got
Kevin Costner is he going to carry me
out as I know
into the side of his neck was simply see
there's no long-term contracts or hidden
fees and around-the-clock monitoring is
only $14.99 a month call to action so
don't spend another night
second-guessing your home safety gets
simply safe and get some rest go to
simply saber comm I'm just picturing
when that hundred five decibel alarm
goes up and you [ __ ] shoot up in bed
with an absolute panic going please let
that be a squirrel that just bounced off
my [ __ ] window you know and why
doesn't everybody have a panic room just
sleep in that [ __ ] maybe if my panic
would be that the [ __ ] door wouldn't
open up and I'd be in there in this
[ __ ] air tight or not airtight but
soundproof [ __ ] room and they had
some cheesy headline after I [ __ ]
died right panic room turns into actual
panic room
sorry that's simply safe bird calm for
10 percent off your order simply safe
calm it's si MP Li
safe calm is there a reason why they
always misspell the words of their
company is that because every websites
taken at this point you know go to Bill
Weber calm B I ll e bill Lee burp all
right how much time have I done here ah
37 minutes well you know what usually I
give you a little more [ __ ] freebies
here but I got to go back to writing
which I really don't want to do Jesus
well you know what I guess I guess
that's what I got to do here oh yeah I
gotta sit down it I do this [ __ ]
rustling I need more [ __ ] on Pedroia
I need more [ __ ] on Grunk I mean where
do you go where do you go with either
one of them I get it he's little and
he's done what else is there what the
[ __ ] else is there
all right that's the podcast so I was
just checking now I'm just you know
trying to get you home okay now you can
listen some music and then we'll have
some greatest hits from a podcast gone
by from Thursday from years ago I have
no idea what Andrew thumbless is going
to [ __ ] pull up but he always pulls
up some good [ __ ] I want to thank
everybody who said that they had enjoyed
listening to mute math em ute math you'd
math all one word they have a new album
you got to check them out you got to see
him live you got to tell your friends
and bottom so you can be the cool person
that told them that there's a band
called new math that look that exists
right I'm telling you as great as their
albums are they were even [ __ ] better
life go check them out if you get a
chance all right that's the Thursday
afternoon just before Friday Monday
morning podcast have a great weekend you
[ __ ] I'll let you know how the roast
goes on Monday all right see it
[Music]
it is
I'm hoping not the fear
I can't really read hey what's going on
it's bill burr and it's the Monday
morning podcast for Monday June 22nd
2009 and I'm going to start this podcast
by apologizing for not doing a pot not
only not doing a podcast last week but
not even giving you guys the decency of
sending out a bulletin with some sort of
an explanation I don't know I'm in New
York right now and I'm working on this
movie thing and it's been raining and
it's been a really it's rained like
every [ __ ] day and its really been
affecting the way the whole shoot things
going so you know I had a lot of nights
where I was walking in at about 6:00 in
the morning and yeah it was that and
then also not to mention my flight
didn't have batteries for my [ __ ]
recorder you know what other excuse do I
have oh I also did a podcast for 25
minutes last Monday and realized that I
didn't even have the [ __ ] recorder on
the dumb [ __ ] that I am your son
[ __ ] that he is yeah so I didn't
have the goddamn thing on and I was
meaning to buy batteries and I never did
and basically I am douchebag of the week
how do you like that
I'm douchebag of the week for not
because I didn't do a podcast you know
we all missed days at work hell a rod
miss two days in a row because he was a
little fatigued he was a little fatigued
you know you make 200 [ __ ] million
dollars you missed the first two months
of the season because your hips [ __ ]
up because I don't know what you get
[ __ ] stuck the needle in too far you
know Jesus that was a cheap shot I'll
tell you guys right now as far as
baseball goes I'm already again I'm
getting into golf and I'm preparing
myself if one more [ __ ] guy that I
loved test positive for steroids there's
one dude in particular if he they ever
name his name I am done with [ __ ]
baseball I'm not going to say who it is
out of respect most you can probably
guess who but I'm going to be done with
this fourth
so this is what I figure I figure
basketball and hockey go you know they
go all the way into like the second week
of June so then all I got to do is I
just got to kill the last two weeks of
June and the [ __ ] in for the four
weeks of July that's all I have to kill
and then then it's going to be preseason
even then they got the Hall of Fame game
right they got the Hall of Fame game I
think that's one is in July and then I'm
good and I don't have to deal with
baseball anymore because I can't I can't
[ __ ] take it anymore you know and
believe me I don't believe in Santa
Claus I'm not like a [ __ ] idiot but
you know sammy sosa test positive what
do you think about sammy sosa I mean I
mean I think Barry Bonds belongs in the
Hall of Fame because of what the [ __ ] he
did before he became this roided-out
monster I mean the guy was he was always
a beast then he turned into the Hulk you
know what I mean
so I mean you whatever do you say he's
better than Babe Ruth I wouldn't say
that because Babe Ruth you know wasn't
on juice but why wasn't Babe Ruth on
juice you know why cuz they didn't have
any juice back then that guy was on the
[ __ ] sauce and he was eating fried
chicken and he was date raping chicks on
a [ __ ] train on the way down to
Baltimore that's what I read you know
he's in the Hall of Fame so why not
Barry Bonds and his huge [ __ ] HGH
head why can't he get in but Sammy Sosa
this is why I say no to that guy because
that [ __ ] was he he wasn't
anybody and then all of a sudden II was
somebody and then he was gone again and
not only did he do roids he got caught
with a [ __ ] cork bat okay what the
[ __ ] else do you need you know what else
do you [ __ ] need at that point have
you bestfriend [ __ ] get on the mound
and underhand the ball to that guy hit
he hit like what 606 home runs I think
he hit like [ __ ] 560 of them in a year
and a half
baseball has been Betty Betty good to
make that shut up stupid you got a
needle sticking out of your shirt pocket
yeah so I think I'm going to be I'm
going to be done I'm going to be done
with baseball
I'm really [ __ ] I'm redone with it
one more [ __ ] guy that I love test
positive you know cuz you know what you
do I don't know about you guys but I go
back to when I was cheering the player
on and getting all excited and you just
feel [ __ ] stupid you know
remember in 1998 who the [ __ ] was
watching baseball baseball was finished
they still hadn't recovered from the
strike the only thing that was good that
was going on was Cal Ripken broke Lou
Gehrig's streak and then all of a sudden
McGwire and Sosa having this homerun
[ __ ] contest and I sat there like some
depression Eric [ __ ] kid boy oh boy
golly gee D just see that one go over
the fence I [ __ ] scalped the ticket to
go watch Mark McGwire hit his 28th home
run against the San Diego Padres as they
say up in Boston [ __ ] I I you know sat
in the upper deck in left field
I watched him take batting practice was
actually pretty funny because at that
point he was such a [ __ ] rock star
because he'd already come close to year
before this dude was such a [ __ ] rock
star that half the stadium was full just
to watch him was was just to watch this
guy take batting practice and he came up
to the plate and he got a standing
ovation like an hour before the game so
everybody's waiting for him to [ __ ]
crush one over the wall and I'll never
forget this they pitched the first
practice pitch in and he laid down a
bunt and everybody laughed in some
idiots booed because because they're
morons you know those are the same
people who would just stand back then
they were just standing around because
there was no youtube that they could sit
there and [ __ ] write their dumbass
comments on
so anyways Jesus Christ you know if
you're not into sports you definitely
not listen to this [ __ ] podcast I got
to have a couple of congratulations out
there I got to congratulate the [ __ ]
Los Angeles Lakers Jesus Christ I got to
admit I did not watch one second of the
celebration I or the last game I just
was sort of flipping in once I saw they
were like up by 15 I was like those
[ __ ] and then you know and then
he
penn comes on it says that they have 15
championships and only two behind the
celtics and which is true but I also
know every [ __ ] LA Laker fan thinks
that the Los Angeles Lakers have 15
titles when they don't they have [ __ ]
ten okay and I believe that the [ __ ]
titles belong to the fans okay what the
[ __ ] did the people in Minnesota
celebrate nothing
those aren't theirs Oh got them it's
such a [ __ ] you [ __ ] mood I just got
I got to do this podcast though because
I know I'm going to sleep till [ __ ]
1:00 tomorrow
my whole [ __ ] sleep pattern is just
out of whack so anyways if you new to my
podcast I do one of these [ __ ]
every week unless unless some [ __ ]
staying out till 6:00 in the morning
that's raining every night so let's get
on with the questions here the question
for the week alright this person says
bill I recently read something online
about Michael Vick negotiating a
spokesman deal for PETA since you now
have your dog how [ __ ] stupid is that
you know like anybody's going to believe
that Michael Vick gives a [ __ ] about
dogs that's like when one like like
Vince Neil [ __ ] gets busted for
drinking and driving and somebody dies
in the car and then like three weeks
later he's like hey this is Vince Neil
you know when you're out partying it up
just make sure you got a designated
driver you know I never understood that
it's like dude where the [ __ ] do you get
off telling me what the [ __ ] I should do
before I get behind the [ __ ] wheel
huh you [ __ ] [ __ ]
um you know what I mean so Michael Vick
is going to be a spokes I don't
understand people at PETA what are they
trying to just embarrass the guy is that
what they're doing like yeah listen we
got so much power we're going to make
this guy come on TV and act like he
gives a [ __ ] about dogs when he clearly
doesn't that doesn't make any [ __ ]
sense when you really think about it
right that's like that be like at some
woman's group having a convicted rapists
go on and be like you know you really
respect these broads they you know they
work hard they'll make you a sandwich
and sorry I'm riffing that was supposed
to be the rapist saying to the ladies
going sorry I'm riffing and the ladies
is supposed to be yelling there's
nothing about making a sandwich in that
statement you know if you didn't get it
I'm really not good at that type of [ __ ]
all right let's let's plow through this
question um all right so we have
terrorist [ __ ] give a 4th of July
tips in the next couple of weeks oh my
god I was literally ready to go into
some hacky [ __ ] Middle Eastern accent
which is really some just me imitating
somebody else doing an Indian accent
somebody from India you know make sure
you both the Buddha father Craig I was
literally gonna do that and I stopped
myself because just out of [ __ ]
respect for myself and you guys as the
listeners okay I swear to God if I
actually did that like and you guys
actually came back next week and listen
to the podcast you know I I would lose
all respect for you all right let's
finish this question all right I
recently read something about online
about Michael Vick negotiating a
spokesman deal for PETA so since you now
have your dog what do you think about
this I think I just answered that I
personally hate the [ __ ] since it's
people like him that would leave a dog
by the bridge or worse after they're
done fighting them not to mention this
is just a ploy to get back on the
public's good side so he can work his
way into playing football again also
since you're now doing the podcast uh
wait let me just address that quite you
know so he can it's just a ploy so he
can get back and pump on the public good
side so he can play football again let
me ask all you animal lovers out there
don't you think Michael has paid his
debt to society I mean what the [ __ ]
else does this guy have to do his dream
was to play professional football it got
taken away he had millions of dollars
he's [ __ ] he has nothing left they
took his house they took his mom's house
the guy did time for [ __ ] with dogs
he went to Leavenworth Leavenworth Sammy
the bull didn't go to [ __ ]
Leavenworth he went right I'm just
literally just said that I have no idea
if he went there or not that's one of
those barroom [ __ ] things you that's
not me say in a bar when no one can
[ __ ] do the research I guess I can
now and then blackberries you know but
you guys are all at your computers I'm
sure everybody's clicking and you
[ __ ] keyboards but you know what I
mean the guy went to [ __ ] Leavenworth
he was the quarterback of the Atlanta
Falcons he was one of the he was on his
way they were talking last night he was
a Michael next Michael Jordan but he's
playing [ __ ] football right what does
he do he has some dogfights people flip
the [ __ ] out right I'm not saying what
he did what he did wasn't [ __ ] it was
bizarre
what he did was [ __ ] bizarre because
I I don't know that I've heard it
dogfights but I just thought that was
like some gangs in New York [ __ ] I
didn't know people still did that stuff
but anyways I mean he lost everything
the guy lost everything he lost two
[ __ ] years of playing he the guy lost
everything and he went to [ __ ]
Leavenworth jesus [ __ ] christ it's
easy you know [ __ ] you Peter
go [ __ ] yourself I'm not doing your
goddamn [ __ ] announcement alright I
spent the last two years trying not to
get raped I lost all my [ __ ] money I
lost my [ __ ] career and I'm probably
going to sign with the [ __ ] Detroit
Lions isn't that enough for you [ __ ]
[ __ ] weirdos why don't you go yell at
Obama for [ __ ] slapping a housefly
like you've never done that can you
[ __ ] believe Obama got [ __ ] foot
it's a [ __ ] house it lands on [ __ ]
get it off me you know how about a
mosquito with it would people at PETA
flip out about a [ __ ] mosquito you
know thought those things carry diseases
you dumb [ __ ] off speaking to that swine
flus back huh good old swine flu you got
to love swine flu as long as you don't
get it or nobody loves gets it I'm
telling you the
you know there's good things you know
sent out the traffic you know let's get
some how the [ __ ] did swap I was doing a
bit about that maybe I can bring that
back about how anytime a new disease
comes out like it can't just be like you
know someone was in the forest and they
got bit by something it always has to be
somebody [ __ ] an animal you know aids
some dude somebody [ __ ] a monkey
you know they [ __ ] a monkey and then
they got on the Concorde and they blew
his stewardess and or a male stewardess
and then there was AIDS
oh yeah yeah I'm telling you yellow
fever dude somebody [ __ ] a [ __ ]
Kyle dude really really swine flu I'm
telling you dude down in Mexico they
[ __ ] if they [ __ ] pigs down there you
know don't see anybody [ __ ] pigs up
here do you shut up everybody comes a
goddamn doctor I don't know where do
diseases come from I think they actually
I don't know I was actually going to say
he done do you think that they would be
[ __ ] I think they would be but would
you think this would you think that they
would be evil enough sorry I was just
making sure this [ __ ] thing's
recording because this happened to me
last week I talked for 25 minutes and it
didn't do you think that they would
actually be [ __ ] evil enough to
actually just create a disease you know
I do
and then actually think that they could
somehow control it and I don't know man
you got you something has to be done
there's just too many [ __ ] people
I've said this before I swear to god I'm
41 I don't have any kids I really think
I should be getting a tax break for not
adding to the traffic you know I think
everybody should be required to wait
till they have 40s to have kids let some
old people die let some accidents happen
you know let some [ __ ] people die so
we don't have to [ __ ] have 19 lanes
highway
you know maybe it's good that people of
[ __ ] pigs I don't know if in the end
of it some people [ __ ] die and then
they don't have eight kids and man you
know does anything I say makes sense
it's just so [ __ ] stupid sometimes so
anyways let me finish with this question
here um also since you're now doing the
podcast on your new microphone system
will we get a chance to hear any more of
you on the road or in an airport I found
those to be hilarious and like the sound
better don't know why the new ones are
too quiet but still free so I probably
shouldn't be complaining hope to see you
on stage soon dude I don't know I don't
know what the deal is with that maybe I
think last week's was too quiet because
I had a problem I didn't just a device
correctly I'm on the road I don't have
the microphone and you know I'm on the
talent end here I'm not on the [ __ ]
I'm not the guy in the studio I'm not
Bob Rock here okay so sometimes they
might be a little [ __ ] up but ya know
a lot of people like those old podcasts
where I used to just go off on people in
airports I don't know I guess I could do
it but it was always easier to do it on
my phone because people dated no idea I
was talking to him but if I sit here
with this [ __ ] device you know God
knows someone will take some 911 statute
and I'll be in some goddamn backroom all
right let's get to overrate it
underrated okay overrated underrated for
this week all right
overrated people who make those that
moves me emotional grunts during public
performances Jesus isn't that yet not
the [ __ ] truth if you're listening to
a firsthand story about saving a
person's life
perhaps but making a noise across
between I'm enlightened I'm enlightened
and I have a stomach pain in response to
a trivial fact gets old quick yeah I
absolutely have to [ __ ] agree with
that one another one overrated this is
one that's going to [ __ ] definitely
get some feedback somebody says public
schoolteachers are overrated
they only work nine months a year get
paid a living wages with full
benefits and pensions and they have a
ridiculously easy job I'm going to pause
there result if I have any teachers who
are listening they're just teaching the
same [ __ ] over and over again every year
and they for the most part suck at it
Wow calculus aside most of the [ __ ] is
really simple like how hard is it to
teach kids how to spell the word tree
every year it's not like the Boston Tea
Party gains a new level of nuance every
year you teach it yet they complained
we're underpaid we're underappreciated
but [ __ ] you're overpaid for working a
semi part-time job that you mostly suck
at you're given a free pass to the
middle of class and somehow the bonus of
a social martyrdom I know I didn't say
that right people are always bitching oh
we need more teachers dude our school
teachers middle class what do you when
you consider middle class 25 grand a
year whatever the [ __ ] they pay those
poor things living off of government
money and having to explain really
simple [ __ ] to children not an easy job
like working minimum wage hauling debris
working the fields or cleaning bathrooms
in convalescent homes stupid [ __ ]
lazy coal miners they don't contribute
to society like we do I guess this is a
teachers talking we hope we helped mold
young minds great job that's why most
people are [ __ ] morons alright
alright dude you know I'm going to
[ __ ] wait on this one I think what
you're doing is you're blaming the ass
of the problem all right dude would you
want to stand there in front of 30
snot-nosed kids 18 of which you probably
have two dumb [ __ ] who didn't wear a
[ __ ] condom for parents you know and
you got to get there with their [ __ ]
brat kid and all these [ __ ] parents
no parent today can admit that their kid
is a douche bag you know not overall no
parent would admit that but you know
what I mean like in a certain situation
they always got a [ __ ] excuse they
got a beedi the teachers was doing this
so they were doing that you know I do do
you want to be a [ __ ] T it's such a
[ __ ] great job dude you go be a
damn teacher I know what you mean dude
nine months a year is the [ __ ] you get
the whole their vacation days are
ridiculous that is a great point think
about that they get all those Jewish
holidays off they get the PTA thing off
they get the [ __ ] Thanksgiving week
off they get like a ten-day vacation
14-day vacation over Christmas February
vacation April vacation and summer
vacation you know and you do come in
from nine to three and I got to admit
even if you are teaching calculus once
you do it for a number of years you got
it down but you know what you can say
that about everybody you know the [ __ ]
we say you know how many basements do
you have to refinish before you got it
down well you know what you got to do
you know I don't know and I think and
anytime we get into [ __ ]
the first thing they cut is they always
cut education they always kind of
education can people have old [ __ ]
books I don't know you know something
talk to some of the people here in New
York and some of the [ __ ] that they got
to deal with in some of the public
schools you know and no matter what they
do the kids never [ __ ] wrong blah
blah blah blah blah blah I will I'll
tell you this I do totally agree with
their hours are ridiculous and the
amount of vacation time if they get is
ridiculous but I got to be honest with
you do think about flying getting on an
airplane and there's that [ __ ]
screaming kid all right now multiply
that times 30 and you got to spend six
[ __ ] hours at least when you're on
the goddamn plane you can ignore the kid
you can put on a Walkman you can't do
that as a teacher you got to actually
somehow get these kids to shut the [ __ ]
up and then teach them how to spell the
word tree you know [ __ ] that you can
have that job all right
actually thought about being a teacher
for a while before I did stand-up you
know I just wanted to somehow be in
front of a group of people and be funny
I remember every job I thought about I'd
be I'd be funny I'll be a cop but I'll
be a funny cup I'll pull people over and
I'll let them go you know that's what I
used to think you know I'd be one of
those guys who gets shot during the
second [ __ ] week because I'm trying
to make friends
you know my pathetic need to be liked
alright let's get into the bad press
thing a few weeks ago I mentioned how
you know there's certain groups of
people that just always get good press
you know firemen always get good press
they're the men and women in the armed
services always get good press and
blobbin for the most part 99% of it is
right all right but if you saw Jurassic
Park and you listen to Jeff Goldblum
explain chaos theory there's exceptions
you know there's no way there's not one
douche bag in the Navy there's no way
there's not one [ __ ] at the fire
department you know there are so I
wanted to hear the stories and here's
one bill is about an army guy bill I
have a story about an old neighbor of
mine who was in the army
most people in the army never seemed to
have anything negative said about them
but that's not the case with me I used
to live next to a family in which there
were six sons and each of them were real
pieces of [ __ ] that's hilarious
isn't there always just that [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] scumbag family you know
every [ __ ] one of them is repeated
dad's a piece of [ __ ] the mother's a
piece of [ __ ] all the sons all the
daughters the dog their car it's just
from head from top to bottom it's just a
piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] family right they
all sit there breathing through their
mouths all right anyways so he goes yeah
they're all pieces of [ __ ] because I'm
talking about the types of [ __ ] who
would drop a hit of acid in someone's
beer and get a kick out of watching the
person trip his ass off every one of
them was arrested at least once the
oldest was the biggest piece of [ __ ] out
of the bunch he shot a liquor store
clerk and I think he paralyzed the guy
from the waist down
but out of all of them there was one who
considered himself to be the prize why
you ask because he was the one who was
in the army
and whenever this guy would come back
home to visit he would bring in quotes
army toys with him this is a great
[ __ ] story
there are a few stories that I remember
one time he had a smoke screen and set
it off in a neighbor's yard there were
there were these blue flames shooting
out the back and just burning up the
grass and in a matter of five seconds
you couldn't see any of the houses on
the street another time he set off a
flare in the middle of the night
I can still see him setting the thing
off he just smacked the end of it on the
pavement I came this little ball of
light that shot up in the sky and then
poof it was daylight out he woke up half
the neighborhood but the worst ever was
when he was home for Thanksgiving and I
saw him out at a bar he had brought home
a [ __ ] hand grenade and was trying to
sell the [ __ ] thing one last thing
about this family they had a [ __ ]
brother who was a [ __ ] monster
like 250 pounds all I did with this
brother was basically keep him locked up
in a room and let him watch a pro
wrestling one year at the 4th of July
Bloc Party they thought it would be
funny to get him drunk and let him loose
at the party that was easily in the top
three scariest moments in my life
no [ __ ] people were hopping fences
in fear this guy he didn't hurt anyone
but he dent the [ __ ] out of a tool [ __ ]
see what I'm saying that's oh there's
always one [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] I
don't give a [ __ ] it's always going to
be that he's trying to sell a [ __ ]
hand grenade
I got a question for you guys would you
buy it I wouldn't I be so afraid I'd
blow my [ __ ] hand off but if someone
bought it I would I'd want to be in the
vicinity and in the opposite direction
of where they threw it I just want to be
there any any military people this is
this podcast is there anything that you
can uh how big is that it's like a hand
grenade you know I mean like if someone
like I'm in a hotel room right if
somebody threw a hand grenade in this
[ __ ] room right and was on the other
side of my bed and I jumped on this side
of the bed like [ __ ] Tom Cruise and
one of those Mission Impossible [ __ ]
movies you know in the movie I live what
happens to me Andrea
life you know what happens do I what I
immediately lose my hearing would
shrapnel go through the bed with me in
the bed just go flying out the [ __ ]
window
would I be alright will I stop asking
questions
alright let's move on here's another one
bill Congrats on The Tonight Show and
the movie thank you and even more so on
the dog I got a pair of let me read this
this is one I should have enlarged I got
a pair of pound mutts mutts two years
ago and it changed my [ __ ] life the
whole thing you said about not even
knowing them a month ago and now already
dreading the day they're going to die
[ __ ] I'm right there with you dogs are
kids who never disappoint even when my
girl ate my cell phone
I loved her you mean my girl dog
actually thought you meant your daughter
that's [ __ ] some idiot all right
anyway she said I still loved her I
never knew I had it in me yeah man I I
got a I got a [ __ ] agree with you
dude [ __ ] dogs are the greatest
goddamn things ever and I respect cat
people but I just I don't get it I don't
get it
cats are like the hot chick at a bar man
they just [ __ ] they come to you when
they need you and then they just I
respect cats I totally respect cats
because they're like loners you know
every once while they pop in a what's
going on you know how you've been all
right take it easy then they leave I
totally get that [ __ ] but like I know
just the way they kind of come and go
and they don't pay rent this is
arrogance to that you know I think dogs
are a lot more appreciative you know I
think they sense I think dogs have a
bigger sense of the monetary system than
cats do plus cat's practice killing you
I don't like that [ __ ] girlfriend I
had years back I you know I just I would
just sense something watching me I turn
around and I catch the cat like stalking
me
it was annoying was annoying that the
thing little thing thought it was going
to [ __ ] do so I mean it could do
something to me alright so I don't need
all you cat people do
like dude let me tell you something that
ding wanted to you know if I wanted to
if I wanted to I could take out one of
the many weapons that human beings have
invented where I could [ __ ] kill a
cat from across the room I gotta tell
you right now Michael Vick was fighting
cats he he would have got community
service people just don't give a [ __ ]
about cats you know but people love they
love dogs
you can trash cats I am telling you can
be in on comedy doing stand-up comedy
and you can [ __ ] trash cats and
people just don't give a [ __ ] but you
start trashing dogs and people really
they really have a problem with it you
know cats the gross they [ __ ] in the
house it's like why can't you just go
outside and do that you know ah is it
ever cuz the litter box ever clean is
there any guy out there you dating a
girl with the [ __ ] cat and the stupid
[ __ ] things they have no boundaries
they jump up on tables there on the bed
there on your chest they were [ __ ] on
the couch you're an animal get on the
goddamn floor fight a cat I can't even
begin to tell you how much I would
[ __ ] torture it you know I would get
one of those little spray bottles with
the water I guess you're supposed to use
to keep them off the couch I would just
do that all the time just in general
shoot him right in the [ __ ] face
that's what I would do you know like a
[ __ ] civil rights rally goddamn fire
hose right to the face
all right I don't know why I had to
bring that up all right cash register
day bill did you see the Lakers take the
championship 99 86 it was awesome yes I
did Phil Jackson now has his record 10th
championship ring on his finger and you
really look like a leprechaun next to
Conan every time I do Conan somebody
tells me that you look like his gay
little brother bah bah bah bah bah bah
he's pretty tall he's 64 I think he's
actually like 6 foot 6
anyways also I was thinking about your
position against self checkout lines I
was at the store the other day
and so there were only two people
working at registers and the other eight
were self checkout lines it was
appalling and half the time a person
uses the self-checkout something
malfunctions and someone has to come
over to help so why the [ __ ] don't they
just put a competent efficient
individual at the register that's just
another example of our increasing
unemployment rate I totally agree with
you people are [ __ ] morons you want
to see a classic example of [ __ ]
morons where all those idiots standing
in line to buy the new iPhone people
have like the memory of like two minutes
now remember when the first iPhone came
out what happened
everybody ran out they bought the
[ __ ] thing they stood in line like
they were going to go see Bruce
Springsteen backstage or some [ __ ] they
get the phone the phone sucked the
service sucked everything sucked it was
overpriced they recalled something and
then two months later they fixed it
right and then the second wave were
better phones for like $200 cheaper so
why the [ __ ] when the next phone comes
out would you run in line to buy the
first one again you know why because
you're a dumb [ __ ] that's why and you're
the same dumb [ __ ] who goes into a
supermarket and uses one of those
automated cashier lines because you
think it's easier you think it's quicker
and you think it's better you're a [ __ ]
you're working for free for the
supermarket's and you help them put
people out of jobs you book [ __ ] a
month ago two people did the job for you
for free you just stood there with your
hands in your pockets whatever do you
know what you fighting a losing battle
people are morons and if you come out
with some shiny new [ __ ] the lineup to
go do it I don't give a [ __ ] what it is
all right there's my little [ __ ]
editorial for the week all right uh
Sports annoying things in sports Pau
Gasol's
[ __ ] face come on Laker fan G you got
to admit it all right you won the
championship you're in a good mood you
got to admit come on if that guy wasn't
[ __ ] playing for you that Vice head
oh that itchy beard it's like is he
doing like what was that show we had the
Queer Eye for the straight guy that's
what he needs he needs like a makeover
you know I think he just realizes he's
weird-looking and he's trying to cover
it up with hair um all right you know
one of these days I'm gonna run into
that guy and he's going to take his size
[ __ ] 19 sneaker and he's going to
stomp me right in the face
anyways over all the time this guy gets
fouled or commits a foul every time he
gets a foul at commits a foul he acts
like somebody committed a crime I know
I've been doing an impression of him on
stage and any podcast listeners if you
come out to one of my shows if anytime
you want to yell that out please do it
in between jokes I would really
appreciate that don't do that during a
joke that moment during my set when I
look lost and I act like I'm thirsty
taking a sip of water but I'm really
trying to think about what the [ __ ] I'm
going to talk next yell it out then and
as an added bonus I'll do my Derek Jeter
impression my Derek Jeter impression is
the impression of Derek impression of
Derek Jeter taking a fastball right down
the middle of the plate for strike one
I do what I do a you know I do a
fantastic impression of what he does
anyways uh PS what do you think of the
Stanley Cup Game seven I thought it was
an amazing game great for hockey and
surprising the wings choked thanks again
for the podcast dude the wings didn't
choke you know that's the new age of
sports if somebody wins that means the
other person choked they didn't choke
they just want the Penguins were a
better [ __ ] team you know I don't
know that was that was a great that was
a great series I liked it and I was
psyched I had mixed emotions I didn't
want to see Detroit win again just out
of jealousy but I'm still bummed the
Steelers won a Super Bowl
you know [ __ ] Patriots caught right
up to him we were one behind them and
now somehow were three behind him again
but uh you know I don't know about a
respect to Steelers I mean they're
always beating powerhouses for their
titles now like the Seattle Seahawks and
the Arizona Cardinals and you know who
knows maybe next year they'll play the
Saints
for the biggest trophy in pro football
I have no right to be bitter I just want
to see the Bruins win a Stanley Cup and
then I'm done and I'm you know a is
another there's another way I'm going to
get out of [ __ ] I'm going to get out
of watching baseball when the rest of my
heroes [ __ ] test positive is uh
Wimbledon Wimbledon tennis starts starts
this week that'll kill another week's
and all I got to do is just worry about
July and at that point there's got to be
some Reena football what are you
football fans who just refused to watch
baseball what do you do during July
maybe I get out of the house and
actually work out you know take up
sailing all right this is the end of the
podcast this one is this one's kind of
short this week but it's late at night
and I don't know if it rains tomorrow
I'm going to end up shooting I believe
have no idea it's very up in the air so
I probably should get some sleep
even though they really don't call us
until 5:00 what can i else can I talk I
don't want us to [ __ ] talk about oh I
added a date that I do not have up on my
website yet hopefully I'll have it up by
the time I post this I am doing another
Monday only show at the punch line in
San Francisco I did one back in March I
did two shows and I just went up and I
just sort of told stories while I kind
of did my act and I had probably two the
best sets I can ever remember having so
I'm sure this time uh I don't know I
know I'm going to have a good time again
I just always have a good time when I'm
up there and I don't know that's it
that's the end of the [ __ ] podcast
I'm getting loopy here I actually know
what I've been doing during the day they
got I found another studio here in New
York work and go play [ __ ] drums and
I'm telling you I'm inching closer and
closer to being able to play that good
times bad times if I just [ __ ] play
drums I swear to God I I would have had
it down by now but I always go like all
these days in between [ __ ] drumming
and [ __ ] but I'm telling you
and when I get that thing down without a
doubt I'm gonna [ __ ] make a video of
it
and you guys can all trash me about what
a douchebag I look like but I'm still
going to be able to play it and my foot
is that you know I'm talking about this
[ __ ] right now because I know most
people don't give a [ __ ] is my foot is
actually is is is aching right now for
the amount I play for like two [ __ ]
hours and I was just working on this
that Jojo Mayer that [ __ ] heel toe
thing I'm going to get that thing down
I'm getting that down and I'm getting
down those fast doubles and when I do oh
boy oh boy I still won't have a gig all
right all right that [ __ ] ending
sucked god dammit alright that's the end
of the Monday morning podcast somebody
sent me an mp3 I said I was going to put
it up this week I just don't have the I
don't have the [ __ ] time right now
when I get back to LA in a couple weeks
I'm going to do it somebody made me a
new intro and if you guys want to try to
come up with an intro I know I got some
musicians out there who listen to this
if you want to write an intro song
somebody a long time ago some band
offered to do that and I never really
got back to them I think they're from
Michigan I can't remember but if you
want to do that go ahead now because
actually kind of know how to use
GarageBand and I could kind of splice it
together
yeah and that's it so that's it people I
will be doing stand-up in New York City
I actually worked the Comedy Cellar last
weekend and I might be at comics this
Wednesday which that would be June 24th
I might be doing it but there's also a
chance that I might be shooting and I
might not be there so it's day-to-day
just like a raw day-to-day and iran if
you're listening I hope you get over
your fatigue I hope you took a nap god
of such a [ __ ] alright you guys have a
great week alright
[Music]
only sack
you
[Music]
most erotic talk outcasts they're going
to call these lips agnostic uncover new
[ __ ] tons of speech I'm speaking in
tongues another must be
[Music]
[Applause]
tell me
[Music]
Oh
mmm
[Music]
Oh